Carol Murphy where did you get the title
passion for Islam it comes from a speech
that one of the characters in the book
gave after his conviction in a military
court basically he was convicted for
organizing for the next elections he was
a member of the Muslim Brotherhood and
he mentioned that he said he was
addressing the public and he said I know
there's a passion for Islam in your
hearts and I thought that was a nice
phrase because I think it captures what
is the feeling of most Muslims that they
really treasure their faith right the
little sub headers the Egyptian
experience when were you in Egypt I
arrived there in November 1989 and I
stayed till June of 1994 so almost four
years did you work for their the
Washington Post what's Egypt like Egypt
is a fascinating country first of all
it's very old it's got about a five
thousand year history it's very rooted
in history and tradition it's got a very
conservative culture it's got a very
homogeneous population and the Egyptian
people are lovely people I mean they're
funny they're kind they're generous
they're exciting they're imaginative but
at the same time Egypt has a lot of
problems it's got a very authoritarian
government it's got a lot of economic
problems each now has almost 70 million
people and you know they all have to
live on that thin strip along the nile
because the rest of the country is all
desert any way to describe how big it is
in land mass well it's a pretty big
country I don't remember the square
mileage but it's probably you know it's
bigger bigger than Texas for sure when
you think back about your experience
what do you remember the most I remember
working very hard I remember
the challenge of trying to find out
accurate information because Arab
governments are not very much into the
mode of putting out accurate information
it was the challenge it was difficult to
get information but the same time it was
fun I mean I liked going out meeting the
people talking to them trying to
understand their views on life which
were often so different from mine what
was or what is the Muslim Brotherhood
did you refer to Muslim Brotherhood is
the largest political opposition
organization in Egypt has a long history
was started in 1928 by Hassan al-banna
it really is the 20th century's first
urban centered mass political movement
based on the political ideology of Islam
it is not legally recognized in Egypt
and a lot of its members who are very
active in recent years have been
prosecuted and jailed by the government
at the same time the government winks
it's the fact that many members run for
parliamentary elections as independence
not openly as Muslim brothers so that
leads to the anomaly of right now you
have about 17 members of Egypt's
Parliament who are widely known by
everybody as Muslim brothers how many
cops Coptics are there in in the country
and what does that mean Egypt has the
largest Christian minority of any Arab
country in the Middle East the figures
are disputed but the generally accepted
figure is about ten percent of the
population which would make it now
between six and seven million how are
they treated they faced a lot of
discrimination official discrimination
none of the governors of Egypt 26
provinces are Christian no president
director of the State University is a
Christian sometimes they meet
discrimination in universities and in
jobs having said that you know you visit
with Christians and they don't complain
about their everyday relationships with
their Muslim neighbors on a personal
level relations are pretty good the
problem comes with you know official
kinds of jobs or appointments they'd
like to get what's the average age of
the Egypt Egyptian population well it's
very young I think the median age is
somewhere between 15 and and 21 you see
it there's a big youth bulge and this is
obviously a problem because all these
people guaranteed a free university
education so if they actually make it
find a place in the university they're
looking for jobs what is the country
make what do they sell they sell cotton
textiles and but their biggest source of
revenue is tourism and along with that
is the remittances sent back by
Egyptians working in other countries to
their relatives September 11th had
something to do with your book and has
something to do with some friends of
yours I know there's a dedication here
in the book I want to show it tell me
who's on this list they're obviously the
first two mother and father right I
dedicate the book to my parents my
mother who still living in Massachusetts
and my father who died in 1994 I also
dedicate it to two people who died on
September 11th one is Richard keen he
was the husband of my cousin Judy king
he was in the north tower at a business
meeting
Francis Grogan is the other person I
dedicated to he was a Roman Catholic
priest a very close family friend for
many years almost a member of the family
and he was in the United Airlines plane
that crashed into the South Tower what's
the relationship sep tember 11th to your
book I just working on this book for
about six or seven years part time I'd
try to get a publisher earlier in 1995
when I was in New York as a fellow at
the Council on Foreign Relations but my
agent who was very diligent wasn't able
to get any publisher interested they
explained that there was sort of a
fatigue with foreign affairs at that
time but I decided to pursue this
endeavor and to write it encouraging
myself by seeing some pretty ridiculous
books and bookstores and thinking if
they can get a publisher I can too when
September Elevens happened the book was
about three quarters done so I wrote a
new proposal I got a new agent and
Scribner likes proposal so I asked the
Washington Post for three months off to
finish it which they gave me and I
finished it in March of this year how
many Egyptians were involved from what
you know in the sep tember 11th story
Mohamed Atta I was supposed he's the
purported ringleader of of the 19
hijackers came from Cairo ayman zawahiri
is an Egyptian and by now many Americans
know that he's if he's still alive is
the top political aide of osama bin
laden in the 22 most wanted men listed
by the FBI shortly after September 11th
I think seven of them were Egyptian and
they comprised the largest national
group so Egyptians were involved in the
attack on US September 11th so what's in
the book that helps us understand why
they were involved
the book is centered on Egypt I use
Egypt as the boilerplate to describe the
Islamic revival in the Middle East and
to describe what I feel are the other
factors that make the Middle East place
of turmoil there are two other factors
besides the Islamic revival one is the
enduring presence of authoritarian
governments in the region and the other
is the failure of the United States to
resolve the israeli-palestinian conflict
now once you get all those factors which
are long-running historical forces and
put them all together you get a very
disjointed this region in disequilibrium
which is what the Middle East is now but
I focus on I focus on Egypt as the
example the paradigm and in this book I
explained the background I try to give
the big picture for all these forces and
the fact of the matter is that we don't
have an environment in the Middle East
returns that turns every Muslim into a
terrorist but we do have an environment
that contributes to the conditions which
allow groups like al-qaeda to to get
recruits because there's a lot of
dissatisfaction there's a lot of inner
turmoil and without in within within
Islam itself and there's a lot of
economic dissatisfaction what is the
phrase there is no god but God mean
where does it come from this there is no
god but God and Muhammad is His
Messenger is the Islamic declaration of
faith the Shahada and this is what a
person declares sincerely when he
converts to Islam what does that mean
what are they what are they pledging to
do what's the lifestyle like well that
depends on what you how you interpret
Islam this is one thing that I think is
a big misconception about
in the West there's not one lifestyle
that Islam prescribed Islam is a very
minimal cradle religion you must believe
that there is no god but God and
Muhammad is His Prophet then you have
five things you must do you must say
your prayers five times a day you must
pay arms which is generally two percent
of your net income you a must make the
pilgrimage to Mecca once in a lifetime
if you can and the last one is fasting
during Ramadan and the first one of
course is the Shahada declaring your
belief in one God these are the five
pillars of Islam this is in the minimal
cradle format or beliefs that you have
in Islam some place in your book I read
where the government appoints the 70,000
Imams in the country there are about
70,000 mosques in the country and a lot
of them were built by the government in
the government you know provided Imams
after the rebel uprising of Islamist
gorillas in the 1990s the government
tried to assert its control over all
mosques because a lot of them were built
privately by individual citizens and
they declared that they from now on
would name an appoint all the Imams to
all these mosques I don't think they've
ever been able to do that first of all
they don't have enough money to pay them
all and secondly I don't think they have
enough Imams to supply every mosque with
a prayer leader this was an attempt to
assert control over the mosques because
the mosques have typically been a place
of free speech and the young Islamists
who were active in Islamic group which
was the rebel group that
darm that caused the problems in the
1990s they used the mosque to organize
around they appointed their own moms
Imams to some mosques that's where they
preach their ideas so it was an attempt
to you know get control of a platform
which had been for free a platform of
free speech which which had been used by
people to get around other restrictions
on free speech in Egypt the Prophet
Muhammad lived when he lived in the
early 7th century he died in 632 and he
was about 40 years old living in
southwest Saudi Arabia when he began
having these revelations from God what
she later recited to people told his
friends about and some of them wrote it
down others memorized what he told them
and about 20 years later after his death
around 650 all these memories of what
he'd told his friends were compiled into
the Quran the Quran is the holy book of
Islam word word of God Muslims believe
this is the word of God which makes it
different from the Bible most Christians
and Jews accept that the Bible are
narratives written by human beings under
divine inspiration Muslims believe that
what's written in the Quran is literally
not Muhammad's words but the words of
God passed through muhammad' can women
go and do mosques oh yes can I pray in
mosque oh yes can they pray alongside
men generally they play pray in a
separate section but sometimes is a
screen between them sometimes there
isn't what's the rule on vales there is
no rule
the Quran tells women to dress modestly
now this has long been interpreted by
religious scholars of Islam and that
women should cover their hair in public
but as you know there are plenty of
Muslim women especially in the West in
the United States who don't cover their
hair in public they read the Quran as
telling them to dress modestly and by
the modern terms of modesty in the
united states that does not require
covering your hair in public now there
are different kinds of veils the veil is
sort of a generic term in Egypt the most
common veil is just a scarf over your
hair now in some parts of the Gulf in
countries like Saudi Arabia the United
Arab aramid you see women covering their
face from here down and this special
veil has a different name it's called in
the cob and Iran you get a different
style all together you get the chador
which is avail it goes down like this
and again in Iran most of the women
don't cover their faces and then you get
Afghanistan where they wear the burka
which is another kind of veil and as
you've seen recently on TV the burka the
whole face is covered in the women have
to look through a little slit you say
there are 1.3 million I'm sorry billion
Islamists are Muslims in the world
correct compared to about a million
Catholics about a billion I mean a
billion camera or a billion point2 so
they're very similar in that side by how
many Christians altogether in the world
oh i think there's I'm I don't think
they're about two billion over all
Christians I think so yeah out of a
population worldwide of six billion
right how did what are the Muslims think
of Jesus and Mary the Muslims believe
that Islam came to perfect to complete
the monotheistic revelations God gave to
Jews and Christians so they Revere Moses
they regard Abraham as their spiritual
father and they Revere Moses and Jesus
as holy prophets that received divine
revelations from God Jesus is held in
high esteem by Muslims he's mentioned in
the Quran they respect his they believe
he performed miracles they don't believe
though that he was the son of God that's
the crucial distinction they also Revere
Mary very much in fact there's a chapter
in the Quran named Mary your own
background Washington Post for how many
years over 20 I joined in the late 1970s
or did you come from what city were you
born in i was born in Hartford
Connecticut but I grew up in brockton
massachusetts and where'd you go school
I went to Trinity College here in
Washington DC a Catholic women's college
how did you get involved in journalism
or did you start I was belated entry I
was kind of a vagabond when I was you
know in my 20s after I finished college
I was so sick of studying I didn't want
to see another book again so I went off
to Africa and I was a teacher for two
years in Kenya and then i traveled
around i went to the Far East and then I
went home and I really didn't know what
I wanted to do with my life and then I
decided I I think I want to be a
journalist so I decided that the place i
would start would be back in africa and
i thought i would go to South Africa and
try to work the journalists there and
break into journalism that way but I
took a side trip to Angola first just
because I was intrigued by the country
and this was at a time and it was still
ruled by Portugal was before the
independence and I was just there for a
visit I was still going to go to South
Africa but I met someone who worked in
the American Embassy there and he said
Carol if I'm
you I'd stay here he said things are
going to be very interesting here in
there aren't many Western journalists oh
there's a lot of Western journalists in
South Africa so I decided to heed his
advice and I got a job teaching english
just to get some money to pay the rent
and then I started pleading for jobs
from Western organizations and I got
hired as a stringer by newsweek and NBC
radio and the London Sunday Times and I
stayed there for about two years as a
stringer freelancing and then I was
arrested by the Angolan government
because they thought that I was working
for the CIA which I was not and they
expelled me and at that time the Post
said ok we'll we'll see how you do come
back and we'll give you a temporary job
to do well we'll hire you so that's how
I get hooked up with the post where have
you worked for the post I've worked in
Northern Virginia in the district and I
also was there correspond in South
Africa for four years that was from 77
282 but you were involved in reporting
on the Gulf War yes I went to Cairo as i
said in november 1989 and i found myself
in kuwait on august second nineteen
ninety the day that the Iraqis invaded I
had gone there to write a story because
Iraq was threatening Kuwait I was late I
had gotten sick in Cairo and all my
colleagues had rushed to Kuwait and
they'd finish their stories and they
were preparing to leave and because I'd
been sick I was delayed about a week and
when I got to Kuwait I was feeling quite
sorry for myself because all my
colleagues had done their story and
we're leaving and so I started trying to
catch up and I was still there when he
invented what God on to take you to get
out I decided to stay as long as I could
I mean I'm sure that of all the Western
was in Kuwait that day I was the only
one happy to be there it was a big story
the second day however all
communications ended but I decided that
I would get as much information as I
could hold on to it till I did get out
and could send it so I imagine to stay
27 days part of that time in hiding with
a Kuwaiti family and I was able also to
send out a few stories 1i sent with a
friend and she sent it by fax and then I
was lucky enough to meet some Kuwaiti
resistance people who had a satellite
telephone and they helped me get out a
couple of stories but then the Baghdad
government announced that any Kuwait
he's found harboring Westerners would be
beheaded or hanged so I decided it was
time to leave so I was taken out in
caravan of Kuwait ease who were going
across the desert to Saudi Arabia I was
dressed like an Arab woman that's time
the veil came in handy did you ever
think you weren't gonna make it hell no
have you ever been to Baghdad yes
several times before the war and after
the war and what would you say would be
the principal difference between a place
like Baghdad in Cairo oh you know for
all its faults and you know in Cairo
does have an authoritarian government it
is leagues ahead of a Baghdad in terms
of openness and you know response to
public opinion a Baghdad is a terrorist
police state the mood is very depressing
there and people are downtrodden and
they're angry not just as Saddam but
also the United States because they've
now been under economic sanctions for 12
years supported by the United States
these are UN sanctions but United States
has been insistent that they stay and
the ordinary Iraqi feels you know why
are you punishing us because Saddam is
not being hurt by these sanctions
but again Baghdad also has a long long
history a lot of input to Islamic
history in the Middle East you totaled
up in your book the number of dollars
spent by the united states on israel
since its creation in 1947 85 billion
dollars about 87 since World War two do
you have a figure on how much we spent
on Egypt yeah Egypt is like the second
recipient second highest recipient its
cumulative aid from and sites is about
55 billion why are we spending that kind
of money on Egypt largely because Egypt
made peace with Israel in 1979 and it
was the first to break through this
barrier of isolating Israel and since
the Camp David the first camp david
accords down states made a commitment
not written but verbally to you know
give egypt a large amount of aid as a
reward the American taxpayer is getting
their money's worth 140 billion dollars
over these last what 50 years I think
they would get a lot more if the United
States put on a big diplomatic
initiative to resolve the
israeli-palestinian issue this has
created a log jam in everything in the
Middle East in economics in politics in
social advancement in educational
opportunities not to mention the loss of
lives and if we could get a fair and
just settlement that both sides would
accept and it is possible although a lot
of Americans believe it's not we would
open a door to a new Middle East and
then we would not have to spend so much
of this aid money on just two countries
there are people who argue those funds
should be reduced
and this us age we spread out among
other countries who need it more than
they do what's the difference in the
number of settlers in the West Bank and
Gaza that you write about between I
don't remember what the years where you
brought it up to the 2002 where there's
something like 215,000 settlers how many
that were there 20 25 years ago I think
in the 1970s that were handful of
several hundred three or four hundred
maybe and most of them were on the
border between the West Bank and Jordan
now there are two hundred thousand
living in huge apartment buildings you
know a huge spreads then you just these
are not tented settlements they're
really communities and a hundred
thousand of those were planted by israel
since the Oslo accord in 1993 and this
is one of the reasons that the
Palestinians are so enraged are the
Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt aware of
this yes of course they are how
important is it to them how often does
it come up in your conversation all the
time I mean if there's one obsession
that it's not just the Muslim
Brotherhood it's all Egyptians one
obsession they have it's the
israeli-palestinian conflict but they
have relations between the two countries
they have diplomatic correct relations
not cordial do many Egyptians get on an
airplane and fly over to Tel Aviv no
they can't for a long time the Egyptian
government restricted travel there you
had to get permission from the security
place to go there when things were going
well you know after the oslo accords
which were in 1993 those restrictions
were eased by the Egyptian government
but even if all restrictions were lifted
there would not be a mess
visit by Egyptians to Israel because
there's so much anger and resentment you
write your book around a lot of
characters that you met over there I did
you meet them back when you were over
there 89 through a knee right right let
me put it on the screen the names and I
want to just to ask you to tell us start
at the top there who is muhammad abdul
muhammad abdul i didn't meet because he
died in 1906 but mom and I'm do is sort
of the intellectual grandfather of
modern Islamists who want to see a
revision of the theology of Islam
Muhammad Abdul was a teacher he was a
judge he was Islamic scholar and he
believed which a lot of Muslims still
believe today that there will be no
advance no political advances in our
country and no ability to become a
modern strong state a lesser has been
reformed in Islamic theology the second
was a Hassan al-banna Hassan al-banna is
the founder of the Muslim Brotherhood
what year he founded it in 1928 and he
was shot and killed in around 1942 I
think and most people believe he was
shot by a secret place of the Egyptian
government why they were angry at him
because a certain portion of his
movement had gone into violent activity
and brothers had been found guilty of
bombing courtrooms killing a prime
minister so what was your goal um
tit for tat send a message get rid of
him how many are there in the Muslim
Brotherhood today well it's hard to get
an accurate estimate because it's not as
I said it doesn't you know operate
openly and have membership rolls but
it's generally accepted that it's the
most organized and largest political
opposition party in Egypt if I'd hazard
a guess I'd say two or three million
activists and probably several million
more sympathizers the third one on the
list help me pronounce it is it Syed say
it couldn't say it couldn't could too
who is he Santa was the he's sort of the
idea log of modern radical Islamists he
was a teacher in a school inspector he
came to United States in the late 1940s
he had a religious awakening he became
very religious he joined the Muslim
Brotherhood and he was a writer and a
scholar and he advanced a new
interpretation of the Koran and
basically it's a very radical
interpretation in which he says that
secular governments are anathema in the
Muslim world we must have a government
that's ruled by God's law Islamic law or
Sharia and the way to attain this is for
a vanguard of Muslims to get organized
and to start political activity and
eventually overthrow these secular
governments his famous book signposts on
the road written in the 1960s banned in
most Arab countries it's sort of the the
Bible for violent Islamic radicals these
days where is he today he was hanged by
Nasser
in around 1965 Nasser was in a head of
the government for how long Nasser was
he helped organize the coup against King
Farouk in 1952 I think Nasser actually
took over himself a couple of years
later 55 56 and then he died a heart
attack in 1970 what happened after that
Anwar Sadat became the president for how
long until he was assassinated in 1981
and then the vice president took over
Hosni Mubarak was still Egypt's
president hosni mubarak and saddam
hussein have been in charge for roughly
the same amount of time just save a
couple of years yes yeah they both
almost got a hundred percent of the vote
are they friends I don't think they're
friends no I I wouldn't call them
friends at all I don't think Saddam has
many friends in the Middle East who
assassinated Anwar Sadat it was a group
of young radical Islamists they weren't
very organized they were infused with
the ideology of sidecut abbr they
regarded Anwar Sadat as a heretic
because he didn't impose Sharia or
Islamic law they were also angry at him
for making a peace treaty with Israel
and they wanted to get rid of him and it
just so happened the plot to kill Sadat
was not this sophisticated in a long
conceived plan it developed quite by
happenstance a young guy who was in the
army his brother had been arrested by
Sadat he was angry at Sadat in this
young man this young soldier was also a
member of a radical cell of a group
called jihad
Cairo and he knew that he was going to
participate in a military parade that
Sadat will be reviewing from a stand in
a few days time so he came up with the
idea of assassinating Sadat during the
military parade and that's what happened
how many people were involved in the
assassination I think they're only about
four guys who jumped out of the the Jeep
that was passing of course there were
others who knew that this was going to
happen but in all five men were hanged
for the assassination and about 150
others got jail terms for their
participation in the conspiracy now one
on the list is abdel her eath my Johnny
re pronouncing Abdel herath maddening
maddening yeah who is he monday was a
young lawyer who was also a member and
an official in Islamic group Islamic
group was the organization of young
Islamist rebels who used violence
against the Egyptian government in the
1990s madani was for while their
spokesman he played a crucial role he
defended some of Islamic group guys in
military courts but he played a crucial
role in sort of organizing and sending
messages and passing out money to the
guerrillas he appears in my book because
he was arrested and in less than 24
hours he was dead when I stood him he
was arrested by the security police the
national security place where in his
office in Cairo and you know it's pretty
clear that he was tortured and they went
a little bit too far I don't think they
intended to kill him but he died the
Egyptian government has never given an
adequate explanation of what happened to
him its initial explanation was that he
had
and asthma attack what year was this
1994 did you know him I knew him yes cuz
I'd interviewed him several times for
stories I was writing on Islamic group
and how old was he when he was killed I
think he was in his 30s talaat Yassin
hammam mm-hmm how close was I there very
good who is he I was he tell us did he
was probably the most important gorilla
operative in Egypt during this
insurgency that I write about in the
book which lasted roughly 1992-1995 he
had been around during Sadat's
assassination he didn't participate in
this Tadasana Sasson asian he did
participate in an uprising that occurred
a few days after Sadat's assassination
then he went oh he was jail for a while
then he went on to become very active in
Islamic group and he was the guy that
you know pick the targets organized the
men to go out and do their operations
sabotage bombs and banks trying to kill
government officials during the
insurgency in the end though the police
found out where he was and raided his
apartment and he died in a gunfight with
them did you know him no I never met
come and what was the impact of his
murder it was pretty devastating for
slummin group because it disrupted a lot
of their organization and he was
obviously the brains behind a lot of
their activity in Egypt after that you
know Islamic group kind of petered out
it had a feel very spectacular attacks
after that the most horrific one being
the murder of over 50 tourists in Luxor
in November of 1997 i think it was what
was the impact of that David's a German
tourist they were mostly Swiss Elster
was it German
when their group of German to somewhere
in the last 10 years oh yes that was
another attack on the mostly Germans
yeah the impact of Luxor was it it's not
really clear who organized it how
whether it was organized from Islamic
group officials who lived abroad who
have been and continued to be much more
radical than the leaders who were living
actually living inside Egypt and it may
have been organized and carried out by
just a small cell who decided to do it
on their own but it it turned so many
people against Islamic group and even
people with in Islamic group were
disgusted by it and what was the impact
of the killing of these tourists on
their tourism which you say is there a
number one industry well even before
1997 during the insurgency when a lot of
tourists were being attacked and killed
tourism went down about fifty percent
tourism used to bring in annually at
that time early 1990s about 3.1 billion
a year went down to about 1.5 billion
and I think Egypt is still suffering off
in the aftermath of not only the looks
or massacre massacre but then the
fallout from September 11th what is the
average income of the Egyptian well
there are different figures for it and
it ranges something we're between 742
1200 depending on how it's calculated
but it's very low what's it cost for an
apartment it depends on where the
apartment is and if you can find an
apartment there's a crucial lack of
housing in Egypt especially in Cairo and
people you know live do anything to get
an apartment and they live anywhere it's
it's one of the big problems seventy
million people in the country how many
people in Cairo about a quarter of the
population I think the last figure i saw
was about 21 million living in cairo how
long is the president allegedly
did to be the president how BG he's
supposed to have one six-year term but
Moe barks in his third six-year term
fourth six-year term how popular is he
that depends on who you ask I mean a lot
of Egyptians like him but a lot of
Egyptians don't like him in general I
would say that the Egyptians are pretty
apathetic or antagonistic towards their
government and who can vote um anybody
who's I think over the age of 18 some
more people from the list is it best ah
we missed our abdul majeed mushy my goo
is he and is he still alive no he was
hanged by the government in 1993 I think
it was the skyway was 18 years old when
he fell in with Islamic group he was
came from a very poor village in
southern Egypt his father was an
absentee parent because he worked in
Saudi Arabia this day we had been a very
good pupil when he was in elementary
school but when he got into high school
he lost interest in he fell in with
Islamic group and he was recruited to
fire on a van of German tourists in a
small town in southern Egypt he fired on
the van no one was killed he was
promptly arrested and then he was tried
in a military court with about 40 other
young militants and he was given the
death sentence did you know him no I
never met him by the time I found out
about him on really went to his home
village he had been hanged when you were
there did you speak the language no I
Arabic is a very difficult language and
I didn't have time I took a course
before I left to learn the alphabet and
a few words I know a few words but I
certainly can't do an interview in
Arabic how many of the Egyptian speak
English quite
to quite a few mean most of the people
you dealt with and interviewed worthy
well certainly in the government most do
once you get down into southern Egypt if
they don't work for the government they
probably don't speak English and then
you need a translator how long did great
britain have control of Egypt well it
occupied the country in eighteen eighty
two and then it would granted Egypt
independence in 1922 but it kept a
military presence at the Suez Canal and
control control the Suez Canal Company
and then that vestigial occupation
didn't end till the 1950s you say that
the 1967 war with Israel has a lasting
impact what is it it was the devastating
defeat for Arabs including Egyptians not
only militarily but psychologically they
couldn't believe that this tiny little
country is real could defeat all the
Arabs this young country Israel was only
created in 1948 and the loss of the
territory the loss of Gaza of the West
Bank East Jerusalem has had a huge
symbolic influence for the Arabs and the
way they see to regain their honor of
their dignity is to have a just
settlement for the Palestinians but when
they suffered this loss they were they
didn't know what to do and how to take
it so they started all this internal
examination an intellectual reflection
and religious reflection I mean some
Egyptians came to the conclusion that
the reason they lost was because they
turned away too much away from God and I
explained in the book oh it's from the
defeat in 1967 that many Egyptians date
this return to personal piety
or pious Islam as I call it in the book
do is slot what is it Islamist it
depends and I define in my introduction
how I used Islamist it's a controversial
term because for some people is used in
a negative way or has negative
connotations but I use it in a very
neutral way and I define in Islam as to
someone who wants Islam and its
corollary Sharia or Islamic law to be
their principal reference points in
politics and culture in education and in
their lives of course what does is what
is Islam Islamic law what's sharia what
does it mean what do you have to do
differently if you follow it in the
early days after Muhammad died and Islam
spread all over the Middle East even up
to southern Europe and to India Islamic
religious authorities these were the
scholars of Islam they wanted a uniform
kind of way to that Islam would be
recognized and people from all these
different cultures were converting to
Islam but they were holding on to a lot
of their own customs and traditions and
people would come to these religious
authorities and they say well Prophet
Muhammad said this or the Quran says
this or what should I do in this
particular situation and they would look
at the text and give an opinion and
these became known as legal opinions and
through the ages these legal opinions
have come to be known as Islamic law
Sharia and within Sharia there's
actually five different schools of legal
thought now what do you have to do
differently if you follow Sharia well
it depends on the person you go to to
give you your Sharia ruling I mean there
isn't one Sharia ruling on say for
example mm are you allowed to donate
your organs to somebody else there's
different opinions among religious
leaders can i smoke most Muslims follow
the Sharia rulings that smoking is
harmful to your body and Islam prohibits
doing anything that's harmful to your
body can I drink no what's my relation
with the opposite sex it's very
conservative I mean there should be no
premarital sexual intercourse dating is
very much chaperoned but again all these
laws depend on also on local customs
where you live you have some statistics
in the book about Egypt you say there'll
be 84 million people there by the year
2015 that fifty percent of the country
is illiterate that 16 million live below
the poverty line that there's fifteen
percent unemployment and that 34.5
percent of the population under 15 what
does that say to you about the future of
that country it's going to be a
difficult future and on top of all those
economic problems there's the political
problems Egyptians want more say in how
they are ruled some of those Gyptians
Egyptians are very secular inclined some
of them are very Islamist inclined so
there's a big you know divide in the
population over what kind of government
we should have and the the current
government I would characterize using a
term from another author as semi secular
it declares itself as Islamic government
but it doesn't make its decisions based
on Islamic preset
it makes its decisions on secular
considerations like how to stay in power
how to build enough roads for all the
cars but Egypt's journey into deciding
and getting a national consensus that
sticks on what kind of government we
should have is not yet over I've got a
couple more names on the list and I want
to ask you about that is it assam l l
ryan Essam el-erian close who was he who
is he is he still alive yes it sums
alive and well living in Cairo he is in
my book as a representative of what I
described as moderate Islamists these
are people who don't use violence but
they believe that Islam should play a
greater role in the public life of the
country and that Sharia or Islamic law
should be more openly observed Assam was
in a meeting of other Muslim Brotherhood
activists and they were planning in
early in 1995 for the upcoming elections
they wanted to participate in the
parliamentary elections that were going
to be held in the fall of nineteen
ninety-five the government was very
nervous about this because they knew
they were in trouble they knew they were
unpopular they just come out of this
Islamist insurgency which should
polarize the country so the government
arrested like about a hundred Muslim
brothers Assam was among them and they
were brought to a military court not a
regular civilian court but a military
court on charges like organizing to
promote the most the Muslim Brotherhood
distributing pamphlets seeking to change
the constitution of Egypt which is true
but that's not you know many other
people would like to change the the
Constitution in Egypt but they did there
was not one charge of violence in their
trials but Islam got five years so for
five years he was separated from his
family
and he was released I think in two
thousand what's he doing now he went
back to his old job as deputy
secretary-general for the doctors
syndicate he's a medical doctor by
training there's one last name on this
list it's mostafa estafa rostam mustafa
rustam is an ordinary egyptian who my
profile in the book as someone who's not
involved in politics at all and he
doesn't like the government he doesn't
like the secular opposition and he
doesn't like the Islamists he just wants
to be left alone and live his life and I
include him in the book because there's
a lot of Arabs and Egyptians like him at
the same time you'll see from my profile
of him he's a very devout Muslim and
Islam means everything to him but he has
a very expansive tolerant interpretation
of Islam you do write a lot about
torture yes I devoted one chapter to
that in which Abdul heareth mudane the
Islamic group lawyer is the main
character a torture is used by every
government in the Middle East including
Israel it varies according to its
intensity probably the worst ones are
Syria end end Iraq but I write about how
torture is is toxic not just to the
people who died and are killed and are
injured by it but to the to the life of
a country and I think I mean the United
States government has been very good in
its annual Human Rights reports produced
by the State Department in in
acknowledging and recognizing that the
existence of torture but we don't really
bring that up much in our
in our bilateral relations and I I think
that this is some one thing that the
United States should more openly address
not just for Egypt but for all Arab
countries if we go to war with Iraq what
will the impact be in Egypt I think
there'll be a lot of street
demonstrations against the United States
the government will be put in a very
difficult situation because the United
States will be pressuring Egypt to
support it and the Egyptians will be
supporting will be pressuring the
government not to support the u.s.
effort I think it'll be it'll exacerbate
all the problems that I've mentioned in
this book how long do you think we'll
continue paying two billion dollars a
year to Egypt well the figure is already
going down under an agreement reached
between Israel United States and Egypt
and Congress I think it's not certainly
not going to go up and I think the years
ahead will see a reduction in that aid
what do you think of living in Egypt I
had a great time it's um was fascinating
to see a culture so different from the
one I'd been brought up in it was
difficult it's very hard to work as a
journalist in an Arab country because
they don't have the openness the open
attitude towards information that we do
here in this country it's very hard to
get accurate information you have to
make two or three times as many phone
calls to get what you would expect to
get in one call you will there ever be a
democracy there I hope so i'm not sure
but you know we have to one of the
things i've tried to get across this
book we have to look at the future of
the Middle East in the long term we have
to look at the war on terrorism in the
long term we have to start developing
policies that we can see will have a
good impact in the long term our guest
has been Carol Murphy of the Washington
Post here's what her book looks like
it's called passion for Islam it's about
her five years in Egypt
you very much thank you very much was a
pleasure